Have you ever been just about to go to sleep,...
...walking through the gates to dream land,...
...only to have the floor pulled out from under you and suddenly, you're falling...
...and then, you wake up.
These frustrating sleep starts have another cool medical name, hypnagogic myoclonus.
When we drift off, the areas of our brain that control motor function...
...are inactivated in favor of those that control our sleep cycles,...
...which is why you can dream about riding your bike without actually moving your feet.
As the sleepy part of your brain fights with the awake and moving parts of your brain,...
...that battle can spontaneously tip back in favor of the motor control side...
...and then suddenly you're like, "Whoa, I'm awake."
Sleep starts aren't the only myocloni that we experience.
Hiccups are an uncontrollable contraction of the diaphragm muscle...
...that we use to draw air into our lungs.
About a quarter second after that muscle contracts, the vocal cords snap shut,...
...creating that characteristic "Hic!"
Scientists still aren't sure what causes them, but possible explanations include...
...hiccups being an evolutionary remnant from a few hundred million years ago,...
...when our ancestors still had to pump water over their gills.
Or, since hiccups mainly happen in mammals,...
...that they started as a way for nursing infants to clear air from their stomachs.